what's up reject nation we're gonna
watch from corridor true today stuntmen
react to that and great Hollywood stunts
number 12
you know I'd make a joke about there
being no stunt category at the Academy
Awards and how messed up that is but it
looks like we won't even have to worry
about that next year because there'll be
no movies to award you know Jesus John
I'm trying to make the videos so we can
get people's minds off of what's going
on in here and all you're doing is
reminding us of what's going on in the
real world now I'm just stressed and
anxious and aggravated with you I wanted
to give a form of escapism and not
earlier doing this room is like this is
the only chance they get get their mind
up there give me a baby wipe do it damn
baby why I'm gonna propose to Stardust
review for every film that they talk
about here download falls on the star to
us at Supercop is that you it right
there yeah right and she always just
follows between the cars
that's her there's no way up yeah she
hops on the train it's a great stunt
sponsors still sheriff's look around to
the end of this video to find out how
you can get two months free a premium
members I have never heard of these guys
and some women react we're here with Amy
Johnson they woke now actress and an
incredible fighter on screen she's gonna
break down some awesome stuff for us
today I always had to be the first woman
I we have the privilege of women 12
times and projects in the town you see
amy was specializing in her craft and
cheese the I'm sinking back carried by
another stunt man with guns take both
our legs and arms too good to do any
trailers revisited yeah yeah yeah I need
to the elevator scene else leave no
there oh yeah he did he doesn't a lot
no man this movie is so damn good so I
really liked this highway scene there's
a lot going on so we shot this and so
many different with a car hanging and we
saw onto a mat on the side of the door
is that you it right there yeah okay so
they don't like a Scarlett Johansson
crazy place and then Chris Evans
actually did this oh really he looks so
scared
that's right looks terrified on the
highway on a door
the truck was pushing that door down the
highway they would remove us we would
like fun that's real yeah yeah and then
they would release us and then we were
all by herself
oh my so that we could get like that Top
Shot there was a car like that and that
was rolling in front of us Wow we were
just like sledding down the highway this
is it smiled right I know there's a car
like flying in front of us how do you
that's not a separate take no you Russo
brothers crazy with what you want a
camera angles we usually just have like
a little bit on the sides and then
thankfully I had pants on and a jacket
so I could hide everything I wanted but
yeah usually women don't get to wear our
many pads cuz we're not wearing much
clothes you gotta be sexy right one more
thing to deal with huh yeah I'm so used
to seeing CG and Marvel movies but
that's like so you guys actually in the
rolling car there you're actually
skating down the highway that's so
dangerous so you do a lot of like
hand-to-hand fighting as opposed to more
extreme Oh
did any guys fall off the door than me
point yeah so actually Arin Tony's
fantastic stunt performer oh man yeah
super serious no covering on his arms no
I know cuz he had that shirt poor thing
like
like small ice-skating paths we're kind
of clear a little bit of padding around
I have a dumb production question like
you rent out a freeway I guess and then
you destroy it my that was the other
double Heidi and then this connects into
me we've had like a rope typing the arm
like a little loop and then I was just
like standing on a platform I jumped off
and this green screen behind me and then
they did a face replacement was it hard
to run mine I'm Scarlett Johansson's
boots like did you have to run in those
high-heeled boots yeah we always have to
run in high-heeled boots or high heels
so we were constantly in uncomfortable
clothing it's a full everything there
were no motorcycle pads for some reason
it's just what they always were
[Music]
Oh God what if you are enjoying the show
and you want to see more of these
episodes please consider subscribing to
the corridor crew Channel I'll tee up
and that's when you throw a subscribe
button not at the very top what's the
[Music]
director of Gemini man one of my
favorite fight scenes of all time yes
there's such like a cool story to this
fight all-time favourite action films
cuz it's a love story and an action film
beautifully shot directed
ingly like this is one my thing well I
think you were paying always has a great
stories to his fights especially this
one I think I'm gonna keep switching the
woman's trying to figure each other out
grabbed us what we can't use it too
heavy the floaty floaty wire work like
that I honestly first you're actually
not fan more of a fan of like you know
the Jacky style a little bit I think
like come on the rooftop chase dude
rooftop chase that is beautiful while
words like implement yes stylin we got
like Americans got to see that more
because I think there's a time for it
and it works really well it's kind of
like just magical
[Music]
these sorts like she's winning and see
what's going on as opposed to like yeah
yeah the choreography is stunning like
the moments are great there's no like
ghost like everything is connecting
everything has an intention and purpose
and there's a lot of back and forth so
one character is going that way the
other community is not like there's a
story in the dance of that work yes
thank you for saying story I thought
people drop that was four five michelle
yeoh has done a lot I was like action in
the past experiment to do a lot of
action she's a dancer but in the scene
she actually has a torn ACL michelle
Yoda's no she tore her ACL in one of the
very first fight seems rude and so she
had recover and fortunately like she's
still degree in these tight shots but if
you look she's not moving very much
unless you get that top shot of the
stunt double
so she still maintained all of her fight
scenes and like did everything you know
that she could with a torn ACL what a
trooper michelle yeoh the one that takes
like the the windshield hit that one
Jackie Chan clip and then the windshield
isn't breaking she falls off into the
road Oh
Supercop Supercop is that michelle yeoh
who can't be stopped
oh and the cars in the background
slightly avoid not running over the lead
actress in the film she herself didn't
she no wait no no no I drove man oh yeah
that's her man and she always just
followed you through the cars like
that's straight and you miss it you die
okay she has to have been on wires right
there's there's outtakes mm-hmm
that's her that's her that's crazy
that's her for sure taking the jump
that's her there's no wires
oops very floaty let me show you I had
never driven a motorcycle before she
filmed this crazy movie stunt that's got
to be a double yeah there's no way if
you've never wrote a dirt bike then CGI
is the 90s man then it's like CJ her
face no Jackie Chan I'm so gonna hit him
cool an action scene or even just a
stunt that you want us to take a look at
we will bring a professional on the show
and we will have them break it down for
you but you have to leave a comment
about what that scene is first that we
know which seemed to break down
I've seen this it's a short film oh yeah
this guy no he's great we brought him
over from Indonesia
his name is Chechen you're calm catch up
we did this recently after the raid kind
of like hit big and really yeah let's do
some more that's pretty cool hey you
know these guys then in Malaya who are
two of my favorite people ever cinema
why were the the robots in our Far Cry
blood dragon well no news has the right
to the bottom
yeah and they do he's a pretty good use
of the Dark Knight music
[Music]
so are you doing this thing we're like
and you go to kick somebody you don't
just kick somebody right like place it
he's got the best question shot what we
wanted you to see that I was taking him
sure sure
I definitely liked Kingdom Brunel yeah
[Laughter]
they dated for three weeks usually
there's one voice like chechik would be
the one voice and then we would know the
scenario and and each person would kind
of like come up with moves that work for
their body yeah we'd all come together
in touch with what have the last day and
that's how it works alarms on on bigger
films is like the stuff performer stunt
doubles work on movements if they feel
comfortable with get like a bunch of
little vignettes yeah and then show the
coordinator choreographer and then kind
of like work from there you go watch
this I need a society to palm do you
guys have to practice this fight scene
before you could do this we rehearsed
once for a couple hours he's great
suppose when you're not actors and stuff
people you can
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's super cool so I hope everyone's
happy and healthy these days I know a
lot of us are gonna be working from home
for the next few weeks so I challenge
you guys to better yourselves with
today's sponsor Skillshare still share
it in online learning to shave just for
this place we're ready to take their
skills to the next level I assume that
most of you guys are here because you
enjoy learning just like myself it's not
the matrix you can magically know how to
do something you have to take the time
I've learnt rate so oh my god
library's so much easier I used to wish
for that different Orioles for example
if you guys want to look at ography
Craig Whitehead actually is a really
good class titled street photography
unlocking the secrets to composition to
be great hue is like on any on
Skillshare cinematography visual effects
design illustration self help yeah
Fitness they make it super easy for
everybody also take a transition these
videos
cinematography illustration and you know
what guys we're offering a two month
free trial of the Skillshare premium
membership to the first 500 people she's
got plenty of time these days that's
something I really want to do myself
from the rest of society so what's the
watch enjoys dancing learning about the
world stunts
Amy here it's actually written a book
called how do some in Hollywood lady
blood work as well if you are interested
in getting into the industry or you just
want to learn more about sunsets
book two and to check out I'm going to
pick up a copy also if you want to
follow more of Amy's work you can check
her out on Instagram for handle Osteen
EE Johnson well a link to all this in
the description below of the book the
Instagram and other cool clips things
that she's been here on corridor it's
all there so if you want to watch more
read more whatever it's all in the
description but Amy it's been an
absolute pleasure having you on the show
thank you for all the awesome insight
and showing us these really cool scenes
that you've been a part of it's honestly
it's an honor and a privilege to have
you talk about Captain America I really
do love this I feel like there VFX
artists react gets more views generally
speaking and this is their second most
viewed segment imagine VFX artists react
gets more views because of the fact that
they themselves are VFX are so just make
sense usually have a great like stuntman
performer to guest star in there but
they finally got a woman in here give
some insight for me personally like I
grew up on so much of Hong Kong cinema
just in the circles I ran in from
growing up in the Taekwondo we're all
that would naturally meet a lot of
people who are in the stuntman world so
it's great that this gives a stuntmen an
opportunity to really let their their
faces and their personality shine
especially considering how now they
duplicate the celebrities face on top of
the stunt in space far too often
nowadays somebody slow down some moments
like that Captain America Winter Soldier
moment when they're really slow down I
go that's definitely not Anthony Mackie
their face has the little like lifeless
dead eyes yes like there's no use in
trying to make them superimpose a face
on there that's one reason why I really
appreciate this matter of fact I'm gonna
pitch you guys a movie idea that I've
always had since that Tom Cruise and Tom
Cruise bit with Ben Stiller and Tom
Cruise / mission impossible 2 at the MTV
Movie Awards consider this idea public
domain anyone can make this I'm never
gonna ride it you guys go ahead write
this movie I've always wanted to see a
movie about an action hero who's best
friends with a stuntman not exactly Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood
this is a competition one day the action
hero is kidnapped but he's not really an
action hero real-life but the stuntman
being his best friend one decides to go
save the day so he has to like that'll
his way through to save the action hero
showing the stud man is the real action
hero dude so it's an action comedy it's
not once upon a time in Hollywood we're
not rewriting history correcting any
horrible events in the past we're just
having fun with fights yeah and the
stunt woman Amy a lot of credit goes to
her especially for doubling for Black
Widow Black Widow was slowly gaining the
proper respect she deserved Iron Man 2
and then Avengers I really remember that
it was Winter Soldier and of course
Scarlett Johansson's awesome performance
in that film but also showcasing her
action sequences specifically in Winter
Soldier I think really catapulted her up
a lot more terms of being loved by the
fan I think a lot of the credit does go
to her because that sequence where she
jumps off the bridge wire wires down and
starts running that's a moment I've
always remembered just from the trailers
alone it's means something so incredibly
badass and I know that she's the one to
pull it off freakin great being that
Black Widow has mostly human powers and
stuff like that throwing all the stunts
and all the fighting prowess into that
movie that is more physical and is more
grounded because you know your central
characters are ones who have a more kind
of gritty Hanahan thing I think it's
perfect and now she's got like you know
famous Black Widow moves and I don't
like the leg thing and everything and it
was cool to go back to like I haven't
thought about Crouching Tiger in a
minute but to also go and look at how
those scenes were made into touching on
the story of the fight is like you've
always pointed out those make for the
best kind of fight scenes person in my
personal opinion it's actually kind of
rare in American cinema where you really
do get that sense usually you do need
someone from like either Hong Kong China
or Indonesia to really bring that into
your film sometimes it might not be
fully in the script so the choreographer
will often come up with that I think
majority of the matrix fights really
have that down and that had the same
choreographer from Crouching Tiger
Hidden Dragon man Michelle Yeoh though
she was like a crush of mine when I was
a little kid and watching her in super
Coppins watching her movies like the
heroic trio
she's
so cool and I know she's a lot older now
so she doesn't really do a lot of the
hand-to-hand combat stuff but she's also
a fantastic actress in the last
Christmas tree and hilarious comedy
chops are on point
yeah it was like more comedy from
Rochelle yes I mean she managed to
actually funny enough make the
transition from action star to just
actor did something that Jackie Chan
wanted to do but wasn't able to do but
yeah foreigner man Michelle Yeoh was
able to pull that off because she was
probably the first action heroine I was
ever truly exposed to and really started
to follow her career the wirework stuff
that they were talking about it I know
there was a little bit of us what
opinion but I think it kind of goes
hand-in-hand with tone and style of
movie and time period as well that kind
of traditional kung fu fighting style
mixed in with some of that wirework
works for something that feels a little
like not too fantastical but a little
bit fantastical with a historical time
period setting the way angley capture
that to it I think is great because a
lot of time to pull off that kind of
infusion into your film you probably
need like an opening scene to establish
that but they don't demonstrate that
these guys can move like that till about
20 minutes in and they don't call
attention to it it's just something
that's out of the world yeah and I think
the rooftop chase scene really made you
invested in that kind of style I think
when you just look at it like a clip it
might look a little strange so when
you're watching the movie I think people
praise that and yeah it was something
that looked very artistic like a dance
when it might look a little strange if
you're just leading with the part where
they're in branches or on water whereas
the rooftop gives you a very solid
foundation to his madness on and and it
does yeah I think it does matter the
time and place because that movie has a
lot of mysticism and has a lot that
borrows from like folklore and stuff
like that so I feel like it's really
appropriate there and it's so true what
she's saying about women fighting always
have to be sexy it's like the guys they
have the exact opposite thing weird yeah
they're very fully cloaked up so
dangerous what they do but safer you can
pat ever yeah exactly whatever you want
exactly so it's safer but the prog they
can land into is overheating that's more
of the conundrum like with the stuntman
who was talking about being black
panther is that it gets like way too hot
in there you could pass out from how hot
it is whereas women they when they have
to do these crazy yes
stuff like they can't really protect
themselves as often and they gotta
usually fight it very revealing clothing
but I think that's slowly changing
Harley Quinn has slightly longer shorts
now that's going okay if I have a next
action scene right she's gonna be
wearing sneakers yeah sweats and a
sweatshirt and it's gonna be the easiest
thing to pad and easiest thing to move
it but the gate is a short fella I
caught a while ago you guys can watch
that on YouTube it's I think it's like
less than ten minutes long it is really
cool when she was talking about that
then they segue to that moment yeah
she's fully clothed that makes sense the
fine the way the camera movements are in
it do feel very Indonesian reminisce and
bless raid and more like the night comes
for us throwing it back to Winter
Soldier the way of how crazy handheld it
was it was the thing that would
sometimes make me question what's
practical and what's just damn good
visual effects because that's the one
thing it's like a lot of people really
love that gritty handheld style I do
agree that's some of the best
hand-to-hand combat probably the best
hand-to-hand combat the MCU has ever
presented in terms of their films I'll
still give it to daredevil in terms of a
compass you know all the MCU those
freeway scenes like I never took time to
appreciate just how brutal that must
have been to going off a ramp on a door
yeah I'm on the freeway dude have it on
roars laughing on pavement like that
yeah I mean usually they're able to kind
of change some of the pavement to make
it a little bit more rubber or foam that
way it doesn't hurt as much I imagine
they did regardless that level of
momentum that you gotta roll down it's
still pretty beautiful no padding yeah
all right guys make sure to check out
the gate on YouTube just type it in and
I'm sure you'll find it it's really cool
really great stuff subscribe to the real
rejects subscribe a corridor if you
haven't done so already click the
notification bell it's in this with a
lamps door glass door gasps door pants
door microwave door oven door
refrigerator door hummus front door back
door adorable
Inc door scanner door
this stores a closet this store is a
window this store is a mirror door in
the floor the door in the floor this
door is a drawer this door slides right
this door is a zipper adorable this
doors for security mister smells
historic trashing it the store recycles
portrait of Dorian Gray
Tarantino loves this door that doors
forbidden this door is a wall is thorn
loved to unlock it imagination
this door is a cabinet oh dude seriously
the lamps thank you so much for your
love and support over time I imagine
that your job especially in these times
is still quite important so thanks for
all that you do say hello to the lady in
the little one and we will catch you on
the next one much love buddy
hope you enjoyed